c'est en posant dans paris match avec
mon compagnon que je vais permettre que
dans quelques années tout le monde s'en
foutent
on a grandi dans les années 90 à un
moment où les personnes homosexuelles
les filles les hommes homosexuels et tu
es nulle part il était pas représenté
je savais que je préférais les garçons
mais j'avais pas de guerre dans ma
famille pas dans les amis de la famille
on connaissait même pas dans le quartier
y en avait pas la télé donc je pensais à
un moment même que j'étais peut-être le
seul et ça ça vous met dans un état
d'esprit assez particulier d'une
solitude des sentiments vous dit
bon c'est que je peux être complètement
normal aujourd'hui j'ai 34 ans je suis
extrêmement extrêmement un mot je suis
ministre et et on m'a proposé de faire
ce reportage et je me suis dit si mon
exemple d'aujourd'hui il peut aider des
jeunes aujourd'hui l'âge que j'avais à
l'époque à se dire qu'ils sont
absolument normal alors c'est génial
et quand je vois les réactions je suis
hyper heureux je vois des réactions de
gens qui se moquent de nous mais je
trouve ça génial qui se moque de nous
parce qu'on est trop bourgeois parce
qu'on a l'air de trop posé ça ça veut
dire qu'on a eu et qu'on commence à voir
cet impact qui est que des gens nous ont
vus que des parents nous ont vus que des
jeunes nous avons vu et se sont dit
finalement bas salaires très habituel
cette histoire pour ça qu'on l'a fait
c'est pour l'impact que ça pouvait avoir
sur les autres et et j'espère que ça va
avoir un impact fort sur les autres et
que ça va parler à ces jeunes il ya une
maman qui me voir en larmes
pour me dire que ce que j'avais dit
l'avait beaucoup touchée
parce que quand elle son fils est venu
la voir elle n'a pas su réagir parce
qu'elle savait pas donc elle s'en
voulait de ne pas avoir su trouver les
mots à l'époque alors que me disait qu
aujourd'hui ça y est c'est très bien
mais que s'il m'avait entendu parler
avant d'autres encore parlé avant ça
aurait été encore plus simple pour elle
quand on a cette présence publique qu'on
soit un élu qu'on soit un artiste c'est
peut-être important de le dire quand
même parce que et le dire c'est avoir
immédiatement de l'impact et c'est
participer à ce phénomène de
normalisation et c'est là où c'est
paradoxal c'est en posant dans paris
match et avec mon compagnon que je vais
permettre que dans quelques années tout
le monde s'en foutent
pour ça que c'est important que ceux qui
s'en sentent prêts et bien accepte de
dire accepte de se montrer un peu plus
pour dire à tout le monde autour c'est
ok si tu donnes la main à ta copine
c'est ok si tu donnes la main à ton
copain c'est pas ok de faire des blagues
en permanence sur les homosexuels c'est
pas ok d'utiliser sale [ __ ] comme
insulte permanente au club de foot mais
pour que cela sa tombe
cette idée insultes gratuites qui
servent à rien c'est ces prêts
conception qu'on peut avoir socialement
il suffit juste d'en voir plus il suffit
juste de se sentir en amitié en
fraternité avec tous ces gens qui sont
en fait dans l'autre vie